الفرنسي زين الدين زيدان من اساطير كره
القدم كان كلاعب ومن بعدها كمدرب ومع انه
ما بدرب اي فريق او منتخب من كذا سنه لكن
اسمه من امبارح ترند حول العالم والسبب هي
تصريحات مسيئه ليست تصريحات خارجه منه
ولكن عنه صاحب التصريحات هو رئيس الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم
اذاعيه مع راديو ايرسين سبورتس فالمضيع
سال رئيس الاتحاد عن تمديد عقده مع مدرب
المنتخب
انه كان متوقع انه يستلم زيدان التدريب
بدل عنه فكان الرد من الرئيس الاتحاد
والتفصيل كالتالي انا لا ابالي بزيدان
يمكنه الذهاب الى اي مكان يريد وهو ليس من
ضمن عمله لم التقي به ونحن لم نفكر ابدا
في الانفصال عن المدرب الحالي يمكن او
يمكن لزيدان الذهاب يريد وهذه الجمله
بصراحه قالها لما سال عن احتمال تدريب
زيدان لمنتخب البرازيل
وزاد رئيس الاتحاد وقال هل حاول زيدان
الاتصال به بالتاكيد لا حتى انني لن امسك
الهاتف لارض عليه
وملح طلعت التصريحات حتى قلبت الدنيا
وانتفض العالم للدفاع كله الى جانب زيدان
ومن كل جهه نادي ريال مدريد اللي دربه
زيدان للسنوات قصدي بيان وصف خلاله
تعليقات بالمؤسسه حيل احد اكبر اساطير
الرياضه في العالم رئيس الاتحاد بعدم
احترام احدى اكثر الشخصيات اثاره للاعجاب
حول العالم وانه زين الدين زيدان وجسد قيم
الرياضه واثبتها الشيخ خلال مسيرته
الاحترافيه كلاعب ومدرب ايضا وزيره
الرياضه الفرنسيه بتغريده قالت فيها انه
تصريحات بتسيء ليس فقط اسطوره كره القدم
والرياضه بل للجميع واعتذرت من زيدان على
اليسار على الصعيد الشخصي كمان طلع
المهاجم الفرنسي يعني
وقال انه زيدان هو فرنسي الا احترام لا
اسطوره من هذا القبيل
ومن بعد كل الضغوطات انتخابات رئيس
الاتحاد الفرنسي من ساعات طلع واعتذر في
بيان وتعليقاته كانت سخيفه وانه لا تعبر
عن اراء ولا تقديره لزيدان كلاعب مدرب ام
زيدان مشاهدينا فمن اول القصه وملتزم
الصمت وما علق اطلاقا